i had actually kind of had grown jaded
uh with the television business a local
news business
because there had been a lot of
corporate consolidation
and uh you know there was less autonomy
at the local level
for reporters like myself and anchors to
pursue stories that
you know i felt like were really
important to our audience there were a
lot of
mandates from the corporate offices and
you know edicts from on high and we're
gonna focus on this
and you know i think that's problematic
with our country right now where you
have a lot less
local news a lot less investment in
local news
and you have less coverage of the places
where the rubber really meets the mo
road in our democracy
and that's in your county commission
meetings your school board meetings your
city council meetings
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host
of john bachman now on newsmax
john bachman welcome to the reuben
report dave great to be with you
i felt that i had to do that a little
more as a news anchor
because i'm with a news anchor did that
seem right to you well i appreciate it
because you know
when i have you on my show i always try
to do the reverse and try to be more
dave rubin-esque
more free-flowing you know i i maybe i
should just unbutton the top collar
you want it right let's button the tie
we're on youtube right maybe i'll unbox
the jack and we can relax a little bit
right let's do it let's settle in
calm down if you want to unfurl the hair
a little bit
whatever you want to do you're okay here
uh listen
i am glad to have you on i feel like
you're the right guy to have on sort of
just a little bit before
inauguration we are in a seriously weird
time
and uh as i as i often tell my audience
i just have this short list of people
that are even remotely sane right now
and i kind of put you on that list
for the people that have no idea who you
are uh just give me a little bit of
a little bit of the john bachman's story
and then we'll talk about the news of
the day well i imagine that's most of
your audience
you know i'm kind of new to this
internet thing i'm a traditional uh
tv news anchor type i you know i worked
for
about 20 years in local news started as
an
intern at waga fox 5 in atlanta
and then went to augusta georgia the cbs
affiliate there w
ada and then moved down to west palm
beach florida
because i wanted to be kind of on the
political fault lines
of american politics and of course west
palm beach palm beach county was one of
those areas
where you have you know a pretty diverse
uh
political population and uh turned out
to be everything i expected and more
you know i come to newsmax from that
perspective i had actually
kind of had grown jaded with a
television business a local news
business
because uh there had been a lot of
corporate consolidation
and uh you know there was less autonomy
at the local level
for reporters like myself and anchors to
pursue stories that
you know i felt like were really
important uh to our audience there were
a lot of
mandates uh from the corporate offices
and you know edicts from on high and
we're going to focus on this
and you know i think that's problematic
um with our country right now where you
have
a lot less local news a lot less
investment in local news and you have
less coverage
of the places where the rubber really
meets the mo
road in our democracy and that's in your
county commission meetings your school
board meetings your city council
meetings
uh you know and we're seeing this right
now i think dave with the vaccine
rollout where you had a very successful
you know operation warp speed on the
federal level and then when those
resources whether it's vaccines
or money from fema when they get down on
the local level
you really see a breakdown and the
ability to execute
these types of national plans and you
know
and here i am you know i i worked so
hard this was always
kind of my goal to get to a place where
i had a national audience
but now now that we're here and you see
the you know the pandemic response and
you know the the disparate response from
you know california and new york versus
florida and how it's affecting
you know the mental health of people and
you know you think about other things
too
uh in georgia or other states where you
had a complete breakdown of confidence
in the election system you realize that
this is really
where our focus needs to be now and so
as we kind of reposition ourselves here
uh looking ahead to the bide
administration
and of course keeping an eye on that we
have got to also
do a better job of introducing america
to
you know state houses and what's going
on at a local level
uh so that we can understand what's not
working in this country i mean this is
still a federalist system we have and
we're all fighting to protect that
and we still have unfortunately we still
have this kind of
laboratory of ideas when it comes to
different you know policies and
prescriptions for problems we have in
this country
and again we're seeing that with this
with this pandemic and completely
different approaches from cuomo
and gavin newsom versus ron desantis and
we know you know sometimes that doesn't
work and now
i'm sure a lot of people are looking at
the florida model and say
maybe florida man isn't so crazy so
that's kind of a winding narrative here
but you know
why i'm attracted to you dave and why i
have you on our show
is because this idea of free thought and
that's why i'm here at newsmax now
because this
provides me the platform to do the
things i couldn't do
as a traditional quote unquote news
anchor
it's interesting i asked you john
bachman 101 a little bit about your
history we talked about covid response
federalism
government television the whole thing so
before we go
any further you work for newsmax yes
isn't that some sort of far right crazy
extremist network john that's what they
tell me
you know the funny thing is too dave um
is it's
all that you know of course in some
people's minds then at the same time
you know i'm a traitor for saying all
the way back in december and just trying
to tell the audience that yes
you know the bar is very high for joe
biden not to become president i think we
talked about this that
at a certain point it was like a space
shuttle that had launched into the sky
uh and if it didn't make it into space
into orbit it was going to be some sort
of catastrophic explosion
that would prevent it and it never
happened i mean we're here now
and you know i think you know when
you're taking flak
from the extreme right as we are when
people calling me a traitor for calling
joe
biden the president-elect or from the
far left because
you know we just want to do something
simple as carrie the president of the
united states speech which i think we
were the only major network to do that
uh this week when the president was down
at the border i mean he's still the
president of the united states and his
words
still matter and nobody really wants to
do that
you know that's just you know what we
tried to do is kind of chart a different
path and provide information
that wasn't being provided for a lot of
people and that somehow dave
has become a radical idea do you find it
sort of tough to be a news anchor
in a time when not only is there
cable news obviously and sort of the
dying dinosaur of the
you know the big three cable news
channels but now there's a whole bunch
of other channels like newsmax then
there's like the gajillion people
on youtube and podcasts and everywhere
else that finding a niche that actually
makes sense that's still
true to who you are uh is is sort of
tough
just business-wise and everything else
yes i do i think it is tough in some
respects i mean i think
um you know there are very few places
that can provide
me this type of opportunity or other
great people we have that work for us i
mean
you know chris rudy our ceo really is a
believer in the idea of a big
tent and you know individuality and you
know the
the you know competition of ideas
and you know that's what he promotes and
it was you know kind of a random way
that he and i met i know i talked about
my background as a tv news reporter i
remember one day specifically
i woke up was reading the newspaper the
palm beach post and i read it a little
blurb there was a great political
reporter who no longer works
in local news he's gone on to do other
things his name is george bennett
he wrote about the fact that sarah palin
was going to a place called newsmax
to visit this was after the 2008
presidential election she was obviously
a lightning rod
and i wanted to go meet sarah palin i
was fascinated by her her story
uh her appeal uh to conservatives and so
i showed up at newsmax not knowing much
about newsmax
and i worked the parking lot met some of
the people who showed up to meet sarah
palin and asked them why they were
interested in her and they liked her
outside her philosophy
um and you know at that same time that's
when i met chris ruddy the ceo of
newsmax
and he and i struck up a conversation he
and i talked about a lot of things
i had expressed at that point kind of my
disillusionment with um
you know the local news business and he
gave me his business card and said hey
let's go to lunch
sometime and at that point i was
interested in
what he had to say about the the
business and you know long story short
that was
10 years ago and he had mentioned at
that lunch the idea of starting
a cable news network because he he felt
like there was a vast
portion of america that even with fox
news and other conservative outlets that
were not being reached
and so you know here we are all these
years later
to have this opportunity to be on your
show
to have this you know new audience find
us as an alternative and a compliment
you know to the spectrum of conservative
media that's available
is just really humbling if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell